[Musique]
m
j'ai commencé le vélo par passion
j'avais 14 ans mais j'allais voir mon
cousin qui courait tous les dimanches en
limousin et puis ça m'a donné envie de
faire du vélo et bien sûr j'allais aussi
à l'école à vélo j'ai trouvé ça
formidable les copains l'ambiance
l'ambiance de la compétition puis j'ai
commencé en minimes cadets et je me suis
jamais arrêté
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs mes souvenirs
qui m'a marqué particulièrement en vélo
c'est d'avoir participé au paris pékin à
vélo en 2008 donc un pari fait qu'un don
qui partait le 16 mars du trocadéro et
qui arrivait le 3 août au pied de la
muraille de chine
et là c'était un événement abord assez
exceptionnel et qui m'a permis également
de participer de voir les jeux
olympiques de pékin
donc
traversé à vélo plusieurs pays être
accueillis d'une façon très très simple
côtoyé différents différents peuples
et puis différents cycliste ça a été un
grand événement
les objectifs à vélo c'est de se
maintenir en forme
- maintenant je fais du vélo pour le
plaisir et pour la santé et lorsqu'on
fait du vélo et bien
on est heureux on fait du vélo pour sa
santé et je souhaite en faire très
longtemps